150 euro blauen gold das sind knapp und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
reaktions video er sollte eigentlich bin
ich ja eher nicht so der typ für
reaction videos aber ich habe mir heute
gedacht kommen dann machen wir mal erst
sehr wahrscheinlich haben die drei schon
gelesen es geht heute nämlich um die
probst kommt man ja heutzutage in
deutschland noch wenig dran vorbei sind
oft diesen trends werden oft
vorgeschlagen hat bestimmt jeder von
euch schon mal gesehen dass wir diese
beiden jungs sind glaube ich zwillinge
ich kenne ich mich ja auch um das und
die machen glaube ich day die videos
erstmal muss ich sagen ich finde es
wirklich richtig gut wenn man sein ding
durchzieht die beiden ziehen volle ding
durch und dann ist es total egal was
andere leute sagen und ich finde es auch
wirklich richtig ich meine wir machen
die unsere youtube-videos das gleiche
gilt auch für mich und es gibt leute die
finden das cool es gibt leute die finden
es nicht cool
und wenn man videos einfach nicht cool
findet und immer wieder schreibt hey das
video ist scheiße warum guckt man sich
das dann an ich meine es gibt leute
denen das gefällt
und wenn es die selber nicht gefällt
schaust du halt einfach nicht an
deswegen akzeptiere ich auch voll ihren
content
es gab so ab und zu mal ein video da
habe ich gedacht ja das wird dann
einfach stumpf kopiert von irgendwelchen
anderen usern bei mir war es jetzt zum
beispiel die logische sache ich habe
damit irgendwann mal angefangen das lief
recht gut und irgendwann habe ich dann
bei denen sich hier auch dieses videos
gesehen ich will natürlich jetzt hier
niemand etwas vorwerfen
ich habe das ja auch nicht woanders
gesehen keine ahnung wo ich jetzt gesagt
habt dieses video großen schatz im fluss
gefunden und schatz im wald gefunden ich
glaube die waren beide in dem trends das
war zumindest bis gestern trends platz
eins hier muss man ganz klar sagen
eigentlich inspiriert von zwei mal dass
ich mich meinen der diese waffe im fluss
gefunden
die finden einen schatz im fluss
beisheim hat sehr gut funktioniert und
da liegt die vermutung nahe dass du dich
gedacht haben kommen das mache war und
ich könnte mir jetzt genauso gut das
video von seinem an dass wir anschauen
ich habe mir das mal wiederkommen
schaust du dir mal die frank buß an weil
ich finde youtube an sich ist eine coole
plattform und ich lancieren das machen
was er will nur wenn man halt
offensichtlich den zuschauer verarscht
mit irgendwas was so gar nicht der fall
war so wie sie es auch früher gemacht
haben diese ganzen feld bringt
auch extrem lustig aber ich finde das
geht dann so weit und das soll ich mir
zusammen mit euch mal anschauen und mal
darauf reagieren man sich schon ich habe
schon ein bisschen durchgeknallt also
ich hab mich das video geschaut habe nur
gucken was so ein bisschen passiert bei
diesen beiden videos und wir fangen
einfach mal mit diesem video einem
schatz im wald gefunden frank buß was
ein halt erstmal auf feld 1 5266 1900
discs das ist ja ein gutes verhältnis
sowie bei einem video wurde den
zuschauern richtig auf mit das ist fähig
sei das ja ganz anders aus deswegen
finde ich es krass entweder die leute
die das gesehen haben und daumen nach
oben gegeben haben sind alle dumm oder
ist es wirklich will
das haben wir uns jetzt mal an ja und
das ist eine sache da geht schon los das
war jetzt nur vor spannend wer tut denn
bisschen paket mit den wald mit 50 euro
oder wolltest du uns war mehr ein
metalldetektor
anstatt dessen kofferraum und damit
gehen wir nicht in ein waldgebiet
[Musik]
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen idee an sich
finde ich echt gut ich meine so ein
metalldetektor kennt man aus dem
fernsehen habt auf jüdische bürger noch
keiner gemacht wie es kommen einfach mal
ein bisschen vor
[Musik]
euro also hier würde ich jetzt sagen
kann natürlich sein dass da jemand
vielleicht beim joggen mitten durch den
wald ein euro verloren hat aber ich
glaube die vermutung dass die ideen
einfach vorher dahin geschmissen haben
liegt mehr gut ich warte ich auf das
paket wird sie dieses erbes die den
schatz finden ja wir sind kollegen
wahrscheinlich überall im wald euros
verteilt ist wahrscheinlich der 1 euro
express durch den wald gefahren hat so
ein paar euros rausgeschmissen
jawohl das ist der deutschland gruppe
ich habe es mal vorgespielt ich glaube
ich finde jetzt leicht
[Musik]
hier setzten vor allem dass behinderte
ist ja der hat diesen metalldetektor
drauf gehalten aber das ding hatte ich
mal geprägt hätten ihn die kiste jetzt
wirklich unter dem weg eingegraben und
vielleicht eine woche gewartet und dann
noch mal hingefahren dann wird man es ja
gar nicht wirklich sehen dass da eine
woche zuvor ebenfalls eingegraben wurde
so ein bisschen die spuren sind ja dann
verwischt aber einfach so stumpf ins
gras werfen und nicht schon ziemlich
frech wir schauen uns einfach was drin
ist
da muss ich sagen jetzt bin ich aber
auch wirklich neugierig was machen sie
das ganze auf seine unschuld das ist das
böse
jetzt stellt sich natürlich noch die
frage aus welchem land kommt denn dieser
schatz den hat bestimmten alter
seefahrer vor mehreren tausend jahren
dort versteckt irgendwas macht ihr denn
mit eurem sound also das liegt nicht an
meinem video sonst
das ist das land das ist leute wenn ihr
den großen schatz haben wollt folgt er
der spur richtung brücke voll der spur
ist und brücke gewissen okay es reicht
mir schon ich meine ich würde es mal so
sagen an sich ist die idee ja cool mit
seinem metalldetektor durch den wald
gehen wenn man dann aber wirklich so ein
schatz findet den man vorher selber da
platziert hat was ja ganz offensichtlich
so ist wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
cooler wenn ihr da was rein tun würde
was wirklich sinn machen würde ich
meinen 230 euro einspeisen doch
irgendwie währung aus dem anderen land
mit rein kann ja jeder meinen 900.000
news über zehn minuten sind ja allein
schon 2000 euro würde ich erst mal
schätzen oder halt dollar also zu
drücken aber wie das mit dem
metalldetektor machen sollen gibt den
daumen hoch
du bist noch vorstellen ja wenn ihr denn
wirklich benutzen würde kann er gern
video damit machen aber diesen schatz
hat ja der metalldetektor gar nicht
gefunden naja ich denke mir halt dann
wirklich so wieso hat dieses video so
viele leicht und nur so wenig discs wenn
es doch so offensichtlich ist dass das
fake ist versteht dass keiner da muss
man sich ja wirklich so was gibt es für
menschen auf dieser welt so wir machen
jetzt weiter mit diesem video platz
zwölf mann noch in den trends großen
schatz im fluss gefunden ist jetzt halt
wahrscheinlich der zweite teil davon
wir sind jetzt vermutlich der spur
gefolgt und haben im fluss dann noch
einen weiteren schatz gefunden denen die
sicherlich nicht vorher da selber hin
getan haben wobei man das dann hier
irgendwie an den dislike sehen kann lag
wahrscheinlich daran weil es in den
trends platz eins war und das andere
video vermutlich nur crankos zuschauer
und angezeigt wurde
die im großen ganzen ziemlich dumm zu
scheinen sein wir schauen einfach mal
hier kurz rein
[Musik]
diese warfen vertreter waren leute mir
folgen der spur 2002 müssen wir zur
birke ja doch letztendlich hat nach roth
der letzte mal war der schatz ich kenne
nicht gebunden und darf man muss jetzt
aber sogar sagen diesmal haben sie sich
ein bisschen mehr mühe geben und den
schatz wenige sind wirklich im fluss
versteigert er da jetzt allerdings
wirklich schon länger drin
dann werde ich nur die man hier sehen
kann definitiv nicht mehr so hell
naja ich habe unglaublich gerne sagt
dann kann ich nur sagen ich will gar
nicht sehen eure anderen videos sagen
manche davon haben mich sogar auch ein
bisschen unterhalten aber ich zum
beispiel hätte ein schlechtes gewissen
wenn man seine zuschauer so krass anlügt
indem man irgendwie was da heraus holt
was man selber rein getan hat versteht
ihr was ich meine
also jetzt bin ich gespannt 50 euro
[Musik]
gut wären das jetzt echte goldbarren
hätten die bestimmt pro goldbarren im
wert von über 10.000 euro
und dann liegen da so ein paar profis
drin die vielleicht dann auch 300 euro
kommen ich meinen wollten da der sinn
wer tut dann in einen schatz goldbarren
für 10.000 euro ungefähr ich kenne mich
da jetzt nicht aus und sorgt ein
abkommen geben bei dem der das findet
auch ein paar 50 euro scheine und louie
vito das gibt es auf wunsch ein gute
1000 euro
juni die hier ab 10.000 ich glaube es
geht wirklich sehr sehr selten im video
und daumen nach unten aber diesmal geben
weil wirklich mal daumen nach unten
ja leute so viel zu direkt schon ich
würde mich immer noch nach oben freuen
ansonsten kann ich euch eins sagen
glaubt nicht immer alles hinterfragt
vieles vor allem wenn ihr noch jünger
sind das ist ganz ganz wichtig wir sehen
uns morgen wieder da gibt es ein neues
video und ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen tag sechs nationen instagram 8
und wir sind uns mit